Thanks to Skillshare for supporting this episode
of Journey to the Microcosmos.
The first 1,000 people to click the link in
the description can get a free trial of Skillshare’s
Premium Membership.
Do you ever look at a microbe doing something
and think, “I wish I could do that?”
I don’t know…maybe you don’t.
Maybe you don’t watch a vorticella casually
grab food from a distance and think, “Wow,
I wish I didn’t have to get up to get a
snack.”
And maybe you don’t watch a single-celled
eukaryote enter a protective cyst and think,
“Huh, wouldn’t it be neat if I could just
chill out in a bubble of my own making when
things get tough?”
And that’s fine, it’s good to be content
with a human existence.
It’s got its perks: we get to think about
things and talk about things and make things.
And for millennia, we’ve turned all of our
thoughts and conversations and creations into
culture and societies, which have helped us
better understand the world around us—whether
through art or science.
We’ve learned about ourselves, about the
stars above us, the rocks below us, and everything
in between and beyond.
And that includes microbes.
We may not have known about microbes until
a few centuries ago, but that doesn’t mean
we haven’t made use of them before—whether
that’s the yeast we used to make beer or
the lactobacillus we used to ferment milk.
But apparently, there is more to life than
food.
And knowing that microbes exist has only led
to more questions about how they exist, which
has only led to more inspiration for how we
can exist.
Counting up all the ways that scientists and
engineers have been looking to the microcosmos
for inspiration would be an endless task.
So today we’re going to focus on one idea
in particular: algae, and the possibility
that one day, algae will fuel our cars, our
airplanes, even our spaceships.
“Algae” is a pretty broad category that
roughly groups together all aquatic, photosynthetic
organisms, whether they are tiny cyanobacteria
or a large piece of kelp.
But the algae we are most interested in today
are single-celled eukaryotes, like Botryococcus braunii.
If you want to find a living Botryococcus
braunii, you can look in fresh and brackish waters.
And if you want to find fossilized Botryococcus,
you can dig through Precambrian oil shales,
where their remains point to another more
remarkable fact: these tiny little algae are
the largest biological contributor to crude
oil in those shales.
Now, it helps that when they’re alive, somewhere
between 25-75% of Botryococcus’ dry weight
can be made up of oils.
So scientists have studied Botryococcus to
see if we can use the micro algae to make
those oils for us.
The search for a way to make biofuels has
taken on many forms in many different places.
In the 1970s, the United States Department
of Energy started the Aquatic Species Program
to explore the possibility of getting algae
to make fuels.
Of course, the process is more involved than
just sitting back and letting algae make oil for us.
One microbe is just one microbe.
Their real power happens when they are grown
in large quantities.
But algae do not come equipped with a manual
on how to best grow them, nor do they tell
you how to extract and refine the oil they
produce.
Scientists have had to unravel and optimize
those steps themselves.
Fortunately, the simplicity of algae makes
them well-suited for experimentation.
But technology isn’t just the sum total
of the research that’s made it possible.
It’s also the economics of how it fits into
the world.
And algae have proven much more challenging
in that regard.
In 2010, the estimated cost of a barrel of
algae-based fuel was between $300-$2600, while
petroleum was just $40-80.
Many of the challenges that create that discrepancy
are biological.
Botryococcus, for example, grows too slowly
to make it work for us.
And other species and techniques have had
their own obstacles.
The Aquatic Species Program ended in the mid-1990s,
and there have been a number of other companies
that have tried and failed to bring algae-based
biofuels to the market.
But as is the case with so much of science,
failure doesn’t end a story, it just becomes
a part of another tale.
The past few decades have been marked by major
advances in the tools we use to study biology
at the molecular and genetic level.
And those tools are still always improving,
providing new ways to identify algae strains,
decipher their genes, and engineer new pathways
to maximize biofuel production.
And even if we never figure out algae-based
biofuels, we’re still living a world made
all the richer because of algae.
Because here’s the thing about biology:
we’ve come a long way in how we understand
it, but we are still really in our infancy.
We are finger-painting with biology, while
nature sketches and colors masterpieces that
will always be eons ahead of us.
But that does not mean we won’t get better.
In fact we have to get better, not just for
the sake of progress, but for the sake of
our survival—to make things that won’t
just improve our lives in the immediate future,
but will also leave our future selves without
catastrophic problems.
We may figure out biofuels one day, but it
will come with new questions and challenges
about how they are made and how we consume.
Human progress has always demonstrated both
our ingenuity and short-sightedness.
And the more we understand the microcosmos,
the more we will seek to use it.
But to use it well, we have to understand
how it fits with the world we have today,
and the world that we want to exist tomorrow.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
We’d like to also say thank you again to
Skillshare for supporting this video.
Earlier, we mentioned using yeast to make
beer, and along with many other things, this
is a skill that you can learn on Skillshare.
The class Beer Brewing Basics, hosted by Justin
Trzaskos, is a course for beginners who want
to learn how to make and bottle their own
beer at home.
In this course, Justin will walk you through
the brewing process and help you make a simple
IPA from a pre-measured beer brewing kit.
It’s beer, but it’s also science.
Skillshare is an online learning community
that offers membership with meaning.
With so much to explore, real world projects
to create, and the support of fellow-creatives,
Skillshare empowers you to accomplish real
growth.
It’s curated specifically for learning,
meaning there are no ads to distract you,
and they’re always launching new premium
classes, so you can stay focused and follow
wherever your creativity takes you.
A Premium Membership will give you unlimited
access, so you can join the classes and communities
that are right for you.
And an annual subscription to Skillshare is
less than $10 a month.
If you’re one of the first 1,000 people
to click the link in the description, you
can get a free trial of Skillshare’s Premium
Membership.
We also wanted to let you know that we have
some new Journey to the Microcosmos merchandise
available at dftba.com.
We have this new Brachionus pin as well as
these Paramecium socks.
And the final thank you goes to all of the
people whose names are on the screen right now.
These are our Patreon patrons.
The people who made it possible for us to
return for our fourth season of Journey to
the Microcosmos.
If you like what we do here and you’d like
to help us continue to do more of it, head
on over to patreon.com/journeytomicro.
If you want to see more from our master of
microscopes James Weiss, check out Jam & Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there’s
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.